hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to finding bigfoot' now
I know I said I was going to play this
game in multiplayer the next time I got
around to it but there are some things
that I overlooked there's actually a map
in this game and no I'm not talking
about this map I see in front of me even
though it would have been good to look
at that while I was playing the last
time but there's a map and a whole slew
of other controls that I didn't even
know we're here
X is Beit Hugh's map V's disguise trap
that's what I needed to do to be able to
disguise and faith all the traps instead
of just laying a meet somewhere in the
vicinity of my trap and not actually on
the trap itself so supposedly if I
follow these instructions I might
actually be able to capture they put I
don't know if that's going to be true
I'm still sick so we're going to see if
sick applier is going to be able to
conquer against Bigfoot if that even
made any goddamn sense at all okay hi
hello
you're not Bigfoot oh it's the break of
day okay so I still get I still got a
chance before Bigfoot is going to come
after me and also I found one of the
previous campers from before but Bigfoot
is still out there and I need to find
Bigfoot before Bigfoot find me alright
here we go I'll come on big for where
you have big boy give me the signal
bullets
give me the tracking bullets give me the
gun this where this is rope I don't need
more rope I'd be the God where did I put
the god bugs in this I don't remember
where that was hello
goblin did the god doll laughs ah here
thankful Rin drumming face
okay so what I need to do is I need to
use the dragging bullets instead of the
stupid bullets that I was using before I
was just trying to damage them
eventually I'm gonna kill them question
mark I don't know if that's under sin
true but if I'm not stupid then I should
be able to one rip this branch too
before before before are you grabbing
for Bigfoot I should be able to find me
a Bigfoot oh damn it
[ __ ] footsteps always mess with me
just like Bigfoot is messing with me in
these woods but don't worry I'm back I
remember last time how you gave me the
runaround by biting my face off and then
I died on a stupid trap but that's not
going to happen this time because I know
the controls maybe a little bit maybe I
don't know it seems like a good spot for
a trap put this bad boy there you need
to mask it after placing it use branches
to do this ok that was a good move with
the night vision there okay extubate V
to disguise so I need to V it ah that's
a quality trap and then no time to me
the meat was in the fridge that's right
oh okay all right
hello meat Oh delicious can I find one
of the campers and take him for extra
meat that'd be nice
better be careful in one a miss to spoil
now would I
no I would not okay drama stealing this
is just yeah that's good okay that
that's good
hey big fine dinner's ready Bigfoot
Bigfoot I know you don't like to come
out in the day I just one say you look
lovely wherever you are I think you're
very pretty and you know your foot isn't
all that big in comparison to the rest
of your body
you shouldn't have insecurities issues
when you're actually very attractive not
to me but to something one thing someone
I don't know maybe maybe maybe it's a
lost cause I'm just trying to build
Bigfoot self-confidence one shout at a
time
just like I'm trying to build all your
self-confidence one screaming raging
moment at a time
oh did I been [ __ ] I'm still sick I have
the flu
that's the thing I got so what I'm gonna
do
I'm oh look at this one even though it's
within stepping distance of my my place
there you know what maybe I'm gonna
rethink against that one but if I look
it's a map I got some map well eight
that's just delightful
oh and it was a swamp up north oh man I
call this guy Shrek eyebrows okay so
what I need to do is rip this branch
because I'm angry I've got issues I need
to work out but also I'm gonna go this'n
way oh that's so handy oh that's so
handy what's this big bridge or gate
type thing I can't see where I'm going
hope I don't run into a Bigfoot is that
the hooting hoots of a Bigfoot or is
that the hooting hoot of a sasquatch
oh no but I think it's gonna be some
time who the hell is Hootie hooting Judy
who the cops are coming
alright so we're reaching some sort of
well ain't that just a big old bag of
dicks it's not a bridge at all - gate
thanks for visiting Jasper National Park
I want to leave help I'm trapped in here
with big five I don't know what to do
with my life I'm kind of lonely I go
onto the woods alone looking for such
marches and Bigfoots I don't really have
anybody to hold me at night besides
bigfooting preferably that's not my
ideal scenario he holds a little too
tightly all right okay I'm a late rep
this is good one yep that's good oh
that's real disguise point yeah that's a
good one
oh this is nice and I'm going to put
this camera in this perspective because
staring at the bridge for
what I call the bridge the gate out of
here would be just play dumb point okay
made a camera so now I can watch this
one to see if the biggest bullet has
been couched alright so that's two traps
very intelligently placed by the
intelligent me
I'm strategic this so that when Bigfoot
comes out at night hopefully I'll be
able to capture him for oh I am healthy
yes I am I am healthy looked at me I've
got a lot of help inside my body
that's how health works yes it does what
the [ __ ] did I put was that on my map
why does it say one I don't like that
says one that doesn't bode well for me I
don't like the sound of that
alright well anyway I'm gonna go this
way that looks like a good good good
viewing point I'm gonna put another trap
right here now I'm gonna put it more in
the accessible area right here because I
think they can swivel can't they it's
going to snow little fun Bigfoot Bigfoot
sasquatch did you get caught by my trap
if I go back home am I going to find you
caught in my trap It was as if you
announcing your presence to me because I
don't think I've heard that noise before
hey bud okay I'm just going to cower in
a corner and try to shy away from me
because they don't want my intestines
ripped out of my body I forgot to put a
camera up there I was so startled by the
Bigfoot the call of the sacrilege now I
got to go back there and put a camera on
it because who knows who did you guys
see that oh that's a deer that is not a
Bigfoot you've got tiny feet you get out
here with your tiny feet you better damn
believe your ass I'm prejudiced
and tiny feet it's a fudge out of here
we're your little dinky dinky Twinkle
Toes [ __ ] you
sorry I get really prejudiced sick Park
sorry didn't mean to do that
angry gotta shoot my fridge
everybody hit this one move move move
moon you look doodles ooh looks like
there's nobody here do loo loo loo loo
loo okay time to meander back and OH
Suns almost going down am I gonna be
screwed the answer might surprise you oh
wait no it won't the answer is yes but
do blue it's so pretty
ah what a good day to die in the woods
by Bigfoot I can't believe I'm so stupid
to come out here on my own what am I
thinking right now probably how sick I
am that's what I'm thinking ah here's my
trap don't step on it glad they made
that real faint so no one could see it
really good design point boo Boop okay
so I got that I got this look I've only
got so many tracking boats can't waste
of shooting bridges but that fridge
popped out at me here was asking for it
I don't know I say something else
horrible ah those are my camera
positions okay I see what you're doing
you rogue I'm a funny feeling I'm about
to encounter sasquatch juice but if I
can just tag them with a few tracking
bullets I think it'll work out a little
better for me than it did last so I
think I'll put it up in a little
clearing over here need to rip another
branch no I'm good my anger management
is being tolerated pretty well these
days
Bigfoot ain't gonna get nothing on me
I'm going to get a whole lot of
something on Bigfoot namely my feet on
his feet just to stick to stitch assert
my dominance
I like this hill right here oh yeah oh
that's the good stuff
I'll meet that up good yeah
love it alright and then point this
camera mammarra right there perfect
okay and then as you can see I've got
the perfect stratagem the distribution
is ideal no one will be able to escape
this when I've got 10% of the entire map
covered god I hate that I think that's
so much
whoa ha ha you've been tracked I think
have you been tracked I have no idea
big boy come back I just want to start
you in pieces come on play a little game
here it's the game I call I'm going to
stab you with bullets and then you die
and then I wrap you up and rope and
dragging you back to civilization kind
of [ __ ] up when I say it like that I
literally am going into this guy's home
I mean yeah he killed a bunch of campers
but they came into his house someone
comes into your living room starts
camping out you know you might be a
little concerned about that just a
little bit right so what does that mean
wait a minute I've got it I can see him
I tracked him good I hit him with
trackers oh I did not need to use that
many trackers
okay well that's a rumbly sound of night
okay but this is good because now I'm
not just wandering around aimlessly
anymore I can actually find him so he's
coming right for me so I'm going to put
another trap here cover that up blast
that with some goop this right here oh
yeah well he's coming right for him wait
maybe he's going for the trap that I set
by the trailer okay all right he's
somewhere right over there sweetie
Bigfoot Bigfoot Bigfoot
by jiminy you goof-goof me good I'm
gonna move you with bullets all right
okay that's how you want to play it
Bigfoot I'm gonna heal well if I'm gonna
die I wouldn't want to do a the
Bigfoot's going back darts the winner
all Bigfoots gone back to your schwa OH
Bigfoot can't take the peen too bad
Bigfoot are you sighs I don't know if
I'm gonna have enough bullets to take
care take him out depends on how much uh
like the traps do in terms of damage so
the would go good doom true he's coming
back to the pool boy okay all right
shouldn't talk [ __ ] ah uh all right how
about this
okay coming right for me oh yeah oh yeah
he's coming right for me oh yeah brother
oh yeah brother he's coming right for me
where you at he'll okay I he'll bring
you back you click oh come in straight
for me Oh right down the line go hey my
trap and my trap
hey hey quit stop that you're such a
meanie push what are you doing Bigfoot
so much angrier than he's been before I
mean what a dick bag Bigfoot is really
letting me down here a lot of high hopes
about Bigfoot okay fine then Bigfoot I'm
out of meat I'm out of traps I'm almost
out of bullets I'm not really forward
all right what do we got here Bigfoot's
across the bridge like a big dick all
righty then
well what am I supposed to do I'm just a
lonely guy in the middle of the woods
yeah really he's close to three okay
close to three he's around here
somewhere big fire big fire I thought
it's big boy he's got the biggest where
you going come back you [ __ ] god damn
you lumbering buffoon fine man you could
go over there I didn't want to mess with
you anyway
bang bang alrighty then well that
doesn't mean oh good so he's no they
lose did the tracker wear off
I shouldn't have shot him with literally
all of my tracking bullets well that's
unfortunate
okay so he somewhere down to the south
and I ran out of tracking this maybe
you're going for one of my crabs Oh Oh
have you been
did you get hit ooh he's at - okay he's
that - right now is it - get out of it
ah
where's two - two - I'm coming for you -
two - [ __ ] oh yeah did I illuminate
your you're eating this you better be in
that trap when I get over there you
better not be out of that trap and
eating my face but I won't
I won't tolerate that that's a big no-no
big no-no in my book okay
what do scheme please tell me he's in
the trap I bet it's not this
come on Korea Korea
oh dammit god dammit he's really running
me for a loop now look douche okay
do-do-do-do-do-do I don't know where he
went
turning dirty damn bear I'm lost I'm
lost
Bigfoot cookie Bigfoot yes a big one I
got it okay so what am i do i'ma try
this again cuz I think I know what I
need to do to catch the Bigfoot I'm a
Travis I think I screwed myself over I
had I was on the right path I just I I
markiplier dit and said went wrong
somewhere
okay beep female markiplier got to do
that that's that's a must take that
rifle take this take that fix battery if
these straps I've got an idea for this
think is gonna work it because I only
have so much meat right but I don't need
to put all the meat right on top of each
other you know what I'm saying I don't
need to use all the meat when I'm doing
this I can use some of the meat and then
put traps around the meat meat and then
hopefully that's gonna allow me to be a
bit more you know thoughtful about what
I'm doing flu okay and then what you
have here you have a main trap and
depending on which one he goes for it he
might go for one they might go for
another who knows but depending on which
one he goes for you can't have the
ability to maybe not be terrible and bad
and stupid like I was a sound can you
hurry up I need it to be night so that I
can get my ass chewed off by a Bigfoot
you know it's always been my dream down
my ass torn off and mounted on his wall
Bigfoot I mean not just anybody's wall I
hope when I die that I can have my ass
immortalized in a statue in my honor
that'd be my dream for all my lifetime
accomplishments and making the world's
most amount of dick jokes and
simultaneously having them be the worst
folks known to man that's my objective
plan to do hope to do with your support
I can get whoa don't give that but sound
of the Bigfoot being activated to me
like that
whoo that ran chills down my spine
Bigfoot for a big boy whoo yeah he hit
something
one idiot wait what did you hit did you
hear my trap over here I realize now it
was that one I realized the crux of my
error you hit the ones over there and I
was dumb and just ran right into you now
I got tracker in you let me just reset
my trap over here which one did you drag
her you have a good job you didn't get
the meat did you no no no you did not
get to me oh and now I got you so where
you at buddy boo Oh other side of the
lake oh so sad for you because I can
shoot that far maybe gonna be a shooting
gallery for me really
oh I see you over there oh I see you uh
what's this bang Oh hit yeah and another
one for you am i hitting you no idea
comedy how do I know if a yeah I think
he's charging ah I think he might be
charging for me no you got to even know
he was being shot at he's so stupid and
lumbering like a lumbering stupid okay
there you go
well I can't see [ __ ] oh really
okay over there somewhere somewhere he's
over there I know he's over there he's
over there
I got again I got again always over the
hill okay oh I almost ran right over my
traps okay you're coming for me Oh Mikey
okay I can get him over the traps the
body where he always gone to the other
one I'm gonna hit him with that I gotta
hit him with another boy
oh no please don't please don't
god damn it who's that
god damn it did I damn it how did he
sneak up on me like that a load of
[ __ ] he's so fast
god damn it stop going towards the
goddamn swamps and face me like I'm
around or a giant lumbering beast man
it's also an option one of the two I'll
take either it's cool
oh wait [ __ ] him okay I think I tagged
him
okay here we go here we go where the
goddamnit
[ __ ] trees where is he there you yeah
get some get some get rid I'm out wow
I've got a trick huh alright yeah you
better run away you tell me he's
actually running away okay good okay I'm
doing some good damage on him but he's
also doing pretty good pretty good
damage on me not gonna lie he's doing
good damage on me alright okay he did
not even able to comment for me Howie
I'm gonna try to tag him before you I
think I got him pretty sure that was
fresh tags okay so what I'm gonna do
next because I can't take another hit
I'm gonna try to reconvene back to my my
traps because I got him a little more
than half health he's got left so if I
can get him back at my traps and I can
at least keep keep close eye on him then
I'm gonna be able to hear you come back
already he smells the meat he knows it
there you know he can't resist it so I
need to reconvene try to get some ammo
well it's gonna be close I don't know if
I'm gonna be able to there's another med
kit back home so I haven't forgotten
about that
but this might this might be dicey may
be dicey just make sure okay
please be lining for - which means we
might feel right by this window here but
what happens if I turn off all my power
oh he'll oh he won't know I'm here oh
he's not even gonna know hey Bigfoot
Bigfoot Bigfoot everybody you can't give
me I'm in like a DMV whoa
[ __ ] whoa what the [ __ ] is too
difficult to you for you for to you what
what a load of [ __ ] ah come on
okay well anyway I failed I didn't know
he could do that that's a new thing that
I didn't know about well then there you
have it so I need friends as it's a
general statement not about this game
but I need friends also to help me track
down the Bigfoot so I can beat the sass
gloutch then I can feel good about my
life so in the next episode I definitely
will have friends tell me along with
this so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always ll see you in the
next video bye bye
[Music]